a small ecoli cell takes only around 20
minutes to duplicate itself how amazing
isn't it ever wondered how does a
single-celled bacterium like this one
adds up new individuals to its
population the reason behind this is
truly incredible and you've heard about
it in your lower grades as well any
guesses what could it be this is all
because of the process called
mitosis by this process of cell division
lower organisms like prokaryotes and a
few unicellular eukaryotes produce new
individuals of the kind this is also
called asexual reproduction so mitosis
helps in carrying out asexual
reproduction in lower organisms
and does it have any significance in the
higher organisms like us as well
absolutely how does our skin manage to
heal the wounds on its own and that too
with the exact same new skin cells is it
possible due to mitosis that's right
mitosis process gives rise to the new
cells which are identical to the parent
cells so if there occurs an injury to
any tissue of the body then the damaged
cells of that area are replaced by new
ones which are produced with the help of
mitosis I not only repair but the
process of mitosis helps in the overall
growth and the development of the
organism and how does that happen it's
obvious that due to mitosis cells make
identical copies of themselves giving
rise to growth of tissues and finally
the organs so the increase in size and
complexity of higher organisms is
possible due to the process of mitosis
so let's have a look at this marvelous
process in detail
mitosis is simply a process of cell
division which produces two new
identical daughter cells with the same
amount of genetic material so are these
two daughter cells exactly similar to
each other yes they are genetically
similar to each other and this is the
reason why mitosis is also called
equational division it's extremely
important to maintain the amount of
genetic material in any cell because I'm
an even number of chromosomes in a cell
can lead to abnormalities like cancer
now before moving ahead with the concept
of mitosis let's get through with a few
important terms first we have something
called the DNA chromatin and chromosomes
so let's find out what exactly these
concepts are we have seen these tangled
thread like structures in the nucleus
any idea what they are well these are
called chromatin if we zoom in further
we find these thread-like structures
appear to have this bead on string
arrangement these beads are nothing but
october's made up of histone proteins
and what about this tree well that's our
DNA molecule yes this string like
structure wrapped around the histone
octamer is DNA and why is this wrapped
in this fashion that's because it helps
in increasing the compactness of the
complete structure the wrapping reduces
the volume occupied by the long stretch
of the DNA keeping its length intact so
it's the DNA which along with the
proteins forms the chromatin structure
and what is this chromosome now in any
metabolically active cell the genetic
material is always present in the form
of these tangled threads that is the
chromatin but during cell division these
threads condense to form a structure
which appears somewhat like this and
this is nothing but the chromosome
structure so is chromatin and chromosome
the same technically yes the only
difference is that the chromatin
structure is generally found in a
metabolically active cell in the form of
tangled threads while the same threads
condense to form the classical higher
order structure of chromosomes so we can
say that the DNA with histone proteins
make up the chromatin while the same
chromatin condenses to form chromosomes
there is one more term that we need to
know of it's called the chromatid
now what could that be this is a single
chromosome now can you tell me whether
this is also one chromosome or half it's
also a complete chromosome in both these
structures these arm like structures
which are attached to the central bulge
are called chromatids in simple words
the thread-like strands which are
attached to this centromere are called
chromatids now in this chromosome
there's only a single chromatid while
this one has two sister chromatids
attached at this common point two sister
chromatids symbolize the duplicated DNA
that means the DNA which is duplicated
for cell division is attached to its
butt
coppy before the actual division this
was about the DNA chromatin chromosomes
and the chromatids in general now let's
get back to the process of mitosis and
have a detailed look at this amazing
process in the next video
[Music]
you